are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
reg wallets have an incredible solution
for you this is mine Sleek stylish and
with an industrial look to it can fit 12
cards with cash on the back using a clip
like this one or a strap we've got one
for the whole team I've got one Francis
has one even our producer Anton has one
but he's from Liverpool so he flogged
his on the black market the great thing
about Ridge is that they give you a
lifetime guarantee which means if you
want you can have only one wallet for
the rest of your life Rich are so
confident in the quality of their
product they will give you 45 days to
test drive their wallet that means you
can get the wallet use it and if you
don't like it you can return it within
45 days because Ridge is such great guys
they're gonna give give you free
worldwide shipping and returns to take
advantage of this incredible offer go to
ridge.com forward slash trigger
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russia men who clean up executed for not
being real men which is correct well for
those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
a lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and we'll have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20. at manscape.com that's 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrade your life
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably around near like
the sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape uh not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one and only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
hello and welcome to a live episode of
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is a progressive YouTuber
goes by the name of Destiny uh please
welcome him to the show and while we do
that uh Stephen is going to join us in a
second hey man uh good to see you
hey what's up how's it going it's great
you've come with the progressive hair so
you're fully on brand it's good to have
you yeah I try my best oh yeah I just
died of this weekend just for you guys
so yeah thank you very much it's very
generous of you uh before we get into
the conversation I just remind everybody
if you want to send in the super chat or
a PayPal with your questions for Destiny
uh we'll read them out in about 45-50
minutes so get those in as we're talking
if there's something you agree with
disagree with something you want us to
put to him something you want to
challenge us or him on uh get all of
that in but uh Destiny's good to have
you on man a lot of our audience have
been recommending you and they've always
said uh you guys say you are sort of
somewhere in the middle but you often
talk to people who lean right or people
who've made the journey from left to
right and this is a guy who's very
principled uh he believes in free speech
and he's firmly in the Progressive Camp
so tell us your story what's been your
journey through life that leads you to
be sitting here uh talking to us
um real quick before I do that a lot of
people say my mic is really blown out
right now it's fairly loud it is yeah
because I don't mind I just assume we're
going to bring it down on our end a
little bit okay gotcha gotcha yeah
you're good yeah I think you're good now
uh yeah all right everybody who was
wondering if it was actually live it
really [ __ ] it really and I I just
assumed you really wanted to make an
impression yeah I gotcha okay um so tell
us your story who was Yeah so basically
the long and short of it is uh I started
streaming video games in 2010 and in
2016 I started to get more involved
politically with the whole Trump stuff
and everybody I guess felt like they
needed to get involved politically so I
kind of jumped on that bandwagon I've
always been from 2016 onwards like
pretty far left Center left in terms of
how I've kind of argued with people I
had a reputation for being kind of a
hardcore political debater and then I've
kind of softened that approach
and nowadays I guess my goal is to just
kind of like show the people on the Left
Right can have good conversations while
still being challenging and critical of
one another that last part is usually
missed from people that claim they want
to have good conversations between the
left and right they usually lose the
critical aspect of it but yeah
yeah well that's a good point I heard
your conversation with our friend Peter
bagossian about this very issues like
how do you have healthy conversations
evil Eve not evil even if you might
disagree about stuff so I look forward
to all of that with you and one of the
things Francis mentioned uh to me
earlier is that you are someone I I
don't know how often this happens but
you've gone from being more conservative
to being more left-wing over the course
of your life so tell us about that
uh I mean I grew up in a republican
household my parents were huge uh Bush
fans so I kind of grew up in that whole
era of you know loving Bush loving the
Iraq War loving the whole kind of neocon
establishment and then as I got older
and as I started to earn more money I
kind of started to see how different the
world was from a very wealthy
perspective versus a not so wealthy
perspective and I kind of noticed that a
lot of stuff feels a little unfair and
that kind of moved my perspective a bit
more to the left hmm
that's really interesting because
normally when uh because part of it was
when you had your son wasn't it Destiny
yeah the lens through which I view his
life is pretty insane there's so many
unearned advantages that he has just
because I'm wealthy that he like yeah
other children don't have available to
them and when I kind of see stuff like
that
um it it makes me yeah it makes me look
at the world a little differently that's
so curious to me because I had a son six
months ago and I'm not gonna lie I want
the absolute [ __ ] best for him that I
can possibly provide uh and if I can get
some more unearned privilege in his bank
in his locker I would love to do more of
that
uh yeah I mean I feel the same way um
so that so you would like you would like
him to accumulate as much unprivileged
as possible yeah of course I mean that's
like our goal right like I bought a
house in the best school district I you
know I make sure that he's like provided
for as well as possible like um yeah I
mean we want to provide our children the
most they can get uh it just it makes me
look at the world a little bit
differently when I can see how different
his life might be versus the life of
another child when the two haven't
really done anything different to earn
or not earn you know different
Lifestyles and and what does a
progressive say should happen about that
then
um I guess like the standard Progressive
lines are usually some some greater form
of uh of wealth allocation to I don't
know like underprivileged schools or
making sure children have I guess food
um you know like free lunches or free
meals during class
um whatever I guess whatever Parts you
can allocate money towards to kind of
like help underprivileged children you
know at least have the same economic or
socioeconomic opportunities as more
wealthier children
that's that's really interesting so so
it's it's a free School meals aspect and
bear in mind I'm a former teacher
Destiny so everybody have a drink he
says that every [ __ ] episode yeah so
I I've seen that so it's free School
meals what else is it
well well just around children or for
the entirety of society or well not just
around children but around society as a
whole
um are you asking me for like what is my
go-to policy list or like what is the
general progression I think he's asking
in the context of honor and privilege
and particularly education uh what are
the things that you think are important
well I guess so when I think of
Education in my mind education is
supposed to be the great equalizer if
you go to school if you show up and if
you put in your hardest work you can
every day there should be like a good
reward waiting for you at the end
um so making sure that like every
schools or all schools have the same
opportunities available to their
children who are there to take advantage
of the opportunities I think is a good
start uh so like one thing that I
thought was interesting was over the
pandemic in the United States in my
child's school every single kid was
issued like an iPad and a laptop and for
a lot of children living in the United
States
um not only do they not have that a lot
of these kids don't even have internet
access to their homes so that would be
like one example of a difference between
like a wealthy school district and a not
so wealthy School District other
differences might be like in wealthier
schools you've got like this plethora of
after school programs that available
these different clubs and groups you can
take part in if you're like a band
student they might issue you an
instrument instead of you having to buy
a rent one it might be the types of
textbooks available to you like it might
be providing graphing calculators to
kids like I don't know there's like all
these different things that schools can
do to kind of like put children on a
better footing to succeed in in school
and then in life
and it would also I imagine be greater
investment in schools to have lower
class smaller cloth sizes etc etc
um yeah I mean I guess if you can afford
a smaller class size and everything
starts to get really expensive but
um yeah it's also not just a money thing
too it's it's figuring out how uh we
have to be critical of our education
system because there are some school
districts that throw a lot of money to
their kids and they don't really get
great results so it's not just a matter
of throwing money into schools as well
it's a matter of figuring out like which
programs are beneficial what works
really well what doesn't work well and
then going from there so I think I want
to say the two most evidence-backed
things I've heard of are and these kind
of seem like no-brainers one is food uh
having free meals available for children
it seems like a no-brainer It prepares
you for the day it puts you in a better
position to learn
um so having free meals available for
children that might not be eating well
at home is a really good thing and then
two uh surprisingly another thing I saw
was air conditioning some schools don't
have air conditioning available and not
having air conditioning in a school
that's really hot like over
um
uh oh God was it like is it is it 28
hold on I'm trying to bonger this for
you yeah like like there'll be schools
in the United States that are over like
27 28 degrees inside and you have um and
you've got no air conditioning for these
kids and the ability for you to like
focus and you know pay attention to
class or work on homework is severely
diminished in those
um in those uh environments yeah yeah
and you mentioned uh food and obviously
children need to eat
why is it that they don't have food
why don't they have well yeah I mean I
don't know it's a really good question
well what isn't that really the core
question here uh when it comes to this
issue because it seems to me that often
the progressive solution is to go well
this thing is lacking therefore we must
provide it whereas I often think that
some I often think that the solution
often lies in finding out why is the
thing lacking in the first place and
there you start to get into real
difficulty because it's issues like
family breakdown it's uh all sorts of
other things that are going on that are
causing that to happen in the first
place and yes you can give that child
food and you maybe should but you're not
looking at the deeper problem and it's
never getting solved
yeah but I find that that I feel like
that's I feel usually when people bring
these points up I'm not saying you're
doing this but oftentimes it feels a
little Pearl clutchy to where it's like
here's a problem I know it exists some
children don't have enough food in
school so provide food because we know
that that boosts um educational outcomes
and then some people like well hold on
what causes that problem well I don't
know I mean there could be a number of
things that cause that problem but I
don't know if I would let there being a
deeper problem stop me from at least
alleviating that symptom oh sure I'm not
I'm not arguing on that point what I'm
saying is isn't there something else
going on that is a sign of something
bigger that we should actually be
focusing on I mean to me family
breakdown is a much bigger issue that
that no one wants to talk about no one
no one is focusing on dealing with
everyone just accepts that this has
happened over the last UH 60 odd years
rapidly where you've gone from like 25
of children being born uh to in a single
pair or living in a single parent
household to like 75 for some
communities or 50 or 40 depending on
which group you're in that to me is a
massive problem why why do we never talk
about that when we're talking with
Progressive people I feel like we talk
about that all the time because I feel
like I hear about this constantly maybe
it's just because yeah of course yeah
where people talk about like children
being born out of wedlock people talking
about tangentially things oh I hear the
right talking about it I never hear
Progressive talk about it
um well I I mean I hear a lot of
right-leading meaning of the United
States I guess what is the when I hear
the right talk about it I never hear the
right talk about solutions to any of
these problems either though what is
like the what's the right-leaning
perspective how to alleviate these
things or rather why is there a family
breakdown
well uh that is very very complicated
and we've had a number of guests on the
show to talk about I mean Louise Perry
would say the sexual Revolution creates
that process because you change the
Dynamics between men and women using
contraception there's uh you know Thomas
Soul would say and he's obviously on the
right it's the the welfare state creates
incentives for people not to live
together uh and for women essentially to
be paid by the government to have
children there's all sorts of
explanations for it uh and that means
that there's you know you're right I
think the right offers few Solutions
other than like let's encourage marriage
but isn't it important for both sides to
at least ask the question then we might
actually come up with some solutions
yeah I think that asking the questions
are fine
um but yeah I'm not going to wait for
the reversal of the sexual revolution in
the welfare state to feed kids in school
like us
yeah that wasn't what I was saying I
think oh sure no yeah I know like yeah I
mean there's always deeper there's
there's always a good line
um but I I find that for deeper problems
it always feels like people are just
trying to smuggle in whatever they care
about the most
um so if you ask like the breakdown of
the family like a feminist might tell
you that it's because men don't respect
women enough and they're not being
patient enough to wait for children to
be born at the appropriate time or if
you ask a conservative or a Christian
they'll say the breakdown of the family
has happened because of um because of a
lack of social values because of the you
know the sexual Revolution and too many
people having casual sex or if you act
like it feels like anytime you ask
people these really complicated
questions it's just an invitation
basically for them to rant for you know
two hours about whatever their
particular pet issue is for all of life
that explains everything now again not
to say that you guys do that but I mean
I agree that these are definitely deeper
problems that need to be looked at but
um
I don't think we're undoing like the
sexual Revolution anytime soon
yeah yeah so yeah yeah I mean if you
want to talk about any of the deeper
things we can go into any of those if
you want for sure I mean they're all
interesting topics um I don't buy the
welfare state one for instance I don't
believe that any Mother's ever made the
choice to have a child out of wedlock to
get more welfare
um we can talk about any of the
underlying issues if you want but um
yeah well I mean I actually don't
believe it either personally because it
happens cross-culturally across
different nations so I don't buy that
argument even though I think a lot of
what Thomas is written is very
insightful
um anyway Francis I know you've got
questions no so the thing though I find
very interesting Destiny is there is a
journey from right to left
do you think the left is better at
private providing Solutions than the
right which is that the reason why you
moved over
um no I don't think anybody's that great
at providing Solutions
um I would say the left is marginally
better because at least most of their
stuff is rooted more in reality than the
right is at least in the United States
when people on the right like don't
think climate change is real I think
some of them don't believe in evolution
might think the world is six thousand
years old don't believe vaccines work
don't believe in um like climate change
yeah I don't it's hard it's hard to
begin a conversation with well how do we
fix this problem when a lot of those
people are completely just descriptively
factually like off off reality
um people on the left though obviously
they do their rotary signaling as well
they say dumb [ __ ] sometimes or a lot of
times
um my personal philosophy doesn't really
revolve around like which side is making
the better prescriptions it's more just
like where do I align that
philosophically in terms of how do I
believe that I guess like the country
should be ran I mean look and I'm going
to push back a little bit on that and
just so you know I regard myself as
being on the left former primary school
teacher and secondary school trained to
private schools for 12 years
etc etc etc economically very much on
the left but surely Destiny when you
were saying like don't believe in
vaccines uh believe in evolution what
you're doing is you're pinpointing a
certain part of the right the religious
right there are lots of people who are
very pro-vaccine on the right there are
a lot of people who are atheists who are
atheists on the right you were just
pointing to a certain part in in a way
which some people do on the right when
they go oh nobody on the left believes
that there's two Sexes and hang on a
minute mate I think there's two Sexes do
you get what I'm saying destiny uh yeah
I mean 48 of Republicans in the United
States don't believe in evolution
um I could look up other numbers if you
want for like vaccines I think 68 of
Republicans don't believe the last
election was real
um I don't but this is what do you mean
they don't believe what was wrong you
mean they believe it was stolen yeah
they believe it was stolen yeah the
election was completely rigged like the
polls were actually or not the polls the
actual votes were were tabulated
differently or ballots were hit or
whatever
um there is a radical Wing to the left
in the United States but that radical
Wing is a fringe it's small it's found
in colleges um it's it's almost
non-existent legislatively and it's
found on Twitter but on the Republican
side on the conservative side the
radical Wing is right now the majority
of the party it's significantly
different so I'm willing to acknowledge
that there's radicals on the left and
right the differences on the right
they've become almost the majority of
the Republican party in some ways and I
wouldn't agree with that idea that like
oh like um not believing in these things
and being hyper religious like that's
just a few conservatives that's not true
in the United States the Evangelical
voting base in the United States is one
of the most is the most important voting
base of the right I think a large number
of Republicans believe in some pretty
surprising things revolving around these
topics but again we can get into any of
those specifications well I mean you
know for us to Growing Up and our heroes
are people like Bill Hicks and George
Carlin who were always mocking those
very people the religious right in the
United States who were at that time
saying don't say this you can't say this
you've done blah blah blah blah blah uh
I mean I would quibble somewhat with the
idea that the the far left has a little
influence I mean I seem to remember them
burning down quite a lot of stuff in in
the middle of 2020 but uh in terms of
the the what I'm curious about you or
someone who's been very strongly and
supportive of the idea of free speech
and that certainly has as a value has
been eroded in recent years on the left
it seems to me at least as an observer
would you agree with that
um I think I don't think anybody really
cares about free speech
um the left has definitely attacked it
as much as they can across social media
institutions or the institution of
social media I guess or Internet stuff
uh but the right wants to legislate a
lot of freedom of speech out of
existence which is really scary to me
and it seems like those ideas enjoy
broad support among Republicans so
uh like legislate Free Speech how do you
mean
um so for instance Donald Trump said
that he was in favor of revoking
citizenship for Americans that burned
the American flag which is one of our
most important rights to Freedom
research he didn't get very much
blowback at all from Republicans for
that
um Republican has uh I'm sorry Trump has
spoken repeatedly about how he wishes to
open libel laws to make it so it's
easier for people in office him
especially to sue media he said
repeatedly that media is the enemy of
the people these are some of the most
worrying statements that a head of state
can ever make if freedom of speech is a
primary concern of yours
mm-hmm but but that's Donald Trump I
mean I really I I find him quite
obnoxious and never was particularly
supportive of him that's fine but the
majority of Republicans in the United
States support Donald Trump and he just
called for like suspending the
Constitution a few days ago so I don't
really believe Republicans are
conservatives when they say they're
worried about freedom of speech I think
that when they say that what they really
mean is they don't like that they got
banned on Twitter okay fine I am or I am
not a republican in America I'm not on
the right I am worried about freedom of
speech uh and one of the reasons we
started this channel is we saw in our
industry which has always been very
Progressive the comedy industry
comedians increasingly restricted
punished canceled uh chased down not not
given opportunities that the other ones
have been given for doing offensive
jokes and or having the quote unquote
wrong opinions so I think to suggest
that people like no one cares about Free
Speech because Donald Trump doesn't care
about Free Speech again your grouping
extremists and with with lots of other
people well the problem is that the
extremist wing of the conservative
partying that it states is the majority
that's the problem extremists in the
United States on the left are a minority
of the party right not many Democrats
consider themselves Communists or
socialists that's like kids at school
where like you're radical far very slow
slim minority people your aocs right but
in the conservative party they're
currently tearing themselves apart
because the majority of the party were
on their knees for Trump for the last
you know four or five years
um well see this is I I agree with you
no no I agree with you I always say I am
longing for the day where I can go back
to mocking the right for hating
Comedians and not allowing them to make
jokes and blah blah blah and I believe
that eventually will happen but I also
think it's clear very very clear where
restrictions around comedy and all sorts
of other speech are coming from
culturally look I hear you about Donald
Trump I don't like Donald Trump but in
terms of the broader culture the attacks
on people's opportunity to make jokes to
express opinions that are controversial
are overwhelming and from the left
Monday when it comes to things like
social media and like cultural stuff
yeah for sure
um I don't disagree with that because
that's kind of where the left has its
power staked out in
um but when it comes to like legislation
uh I mean I would say that the
conservative threat is bigger there
and and so what what do you mean by
extremists let's actually break that
down because where you we're using the
word extremists and like all of these
words they mean different things to
different people and in context and
whatever else so tell us what you mean
by extremist destination sure so I would
say that Trump for all intents and
purposes given the ability to run the
government as he would is about as close
to a fascist as you could be without
actually being a fashion or maybe he's a
fashion I'm not sure anybody that
supports Donald Trump even if you're
like well I don't like him that much but
I guess it's an extremist by by any
definition
um the the fact that January 6 happened
and most Republicans don't care about it
um the fact that so many of them a
majority of them don't believe that the
last election was done correctly that it
was rigged
um these are the ideas of extremists
again in the spirit of just uh comparing
things so I remember and this look I am
sort of like sitting observing from both
sides we're not in America I really
don't affiliate myself with either side
of the political Spectrum I remember
quite distinctly Hillary Clinton saying
Donald Trump is an illegitimate
president in 2016. I personally know
plenty of people in media and in
politics and in all of these spheres who
flat out denied that Donald Trump was
legitimately elected in 2016. who said
it was Russia Collision I mean look I
was one of them I remember going on
stage I'm originally from Russia and
talking about how we helped to get Trump
elected right because it was so much in
the air the idea was he was he was
elected illegitimately so
I find it hard to collect my pearls when
the Republicans would do it even though
I disagree with it I think the last
election was fine despite various
Shenanigans including the hunter Biden
suppression and blah blah I'm just
saying I think to present this as the
extremism of one side when both parties
now do it unfortunately is that accurate
is that reasonable nope it's the most
interactive thing in the world I've
heard this talking a point and and
rebuted it like rebutted it like 50
billion times so everybody will point
out the one quote where Hillary Clinton
said that Donald Trump was an
illegitimate president that one quote
Donald Trump has made 50 000 other
statements saying that the election was
right he repeats himself quite a lot but
that isn't the point
if I'm on stage as a comedian doing
these jokes because it's in the culture
and everyone laughs because they
recognize the quote-unquote truth in it
isn't that the point
it is exactly the point if we look at
the behavior of the democratic party and
the Democratic establishment versus the
behavior of the Republican Party
Republican leaders in the Republican
establishment the difference is night
and day Hillary Clinton ceded the
election the night of Donald Trump tried
to claim victory before the votes were
even counted okay Hillary Clinton gave
one interview where she was salty and
she said something about him being an
illegitimate president Donald Trump
asked his vice president to overturn the
results of the election there have been
a couple of people online that have gone
too far for sure with the Russia
collusion stuff and it's pretty cringe
Donald Trump on January 6 basically LED
his followers into an attempted coup
d'etat of the government of which some
people The Oath Keepers have been
charged with sedition the comparison is
not even remotely closed and I can't
believe anybody would try to say that
two things are similar like yeah you can
give me a few quotes that are stupid by
liberal leaders that have said dumb [ __ ]
about Trump that they shouldn't have
said and I agree with that but to say
that the two sides are the same on that
when Donald Trump to this day still
believes the election was actually
rigged I don't think it's even remotely
confident do you think Hillary Clinton
to this day believes that she lost that
election Clarence Square well fair and
square and and actual rigged election
are two different things right well
Russia collusion do you think she
believes that the election was taken
away from her by Russian Collision well
we already know that there was some form
of Russia collusion right we already
know that like yes that some of the DNC
hacks for instance was done by Russia
that there was coordination between the
guccifer people and Wikileaks in order
to time leaks to damage Hillary
Clinton's campaign we already know from
the Mueller indictments that there was a
company set up in the United States one
of them being the internet research
research agency that was literally
setting up a protests where they were
organizing both sides of it to turn
Americans against each other we already
know that that 10 GOP account that had
more followers than the actual Tennessee
GOP account was ran by people that were
operating at the Kremlin like we know
that that's real now whether or not like
Trump himself was personally making
requests while he did on TV but maybe
that was a joke right like that maybe
wasn't proven as much but like yeah we
know that there was some level of
Russian meddling in order to try and get
Trump elected no we do know that and I
as someone who's from Russia believe me
I I know all about the bot farms and
whatever I just I you say that Donald
Trump to this day believes that he
didn't lose the election I agree with
that and I think he's wrong does Hillary
Clinton believe she didn't lose the
election I'm pretty sure she still
believes the election was taken away
from her unfairly well again she she
believes that she lost the election
she's just going to argue over like what
were the causes that happened that made
the election go the way that it did but
that's fundamentally different than
saying the vote totals were rigged it's
a totally wildly different claim I see
your point that's a fair point and what
would you say say to those people who go
look you know most of most of the
Republicans at the time didn't want
Trump has a different family it was
different fan base different voter base
to a lot of a lot of the Republican
Party he brings his own people with him
a voter base that has been untapped for
a long time who have been neglected who
are a sizable portion of them were
Bernie Sanders fans so what what would
you say to them and that particular
argument
um look at any polling data ever to know
that that's not true I mean Trump enjoys
wide and Broad support from the
Republican Party he didn't bring over
that many Bernie voters
um Trump was a very popular he won a
huge primary like he smashed it with
Republicans
um the idea that Trump just brought some
voters out of nowhere or something is
just yeah oh he did he brought a lot of
people out who never voted for anyone as
well it happened the same with brexit in
this country millions of people actually
um but anyway sorry Francis
looks exactly like most Republican voter
bases there wasn't I'm not aware of this
like
a whole bunch of not I'm sure there are
a lot of new voters because it was like
a really big election same thing with
Obama
um but it's not like he like brought out
some never before seen voter base of
like a group of people that were
untapped or whatever like it's the same
Republican voters as always like but he
still enjoys broad support the
Republican party from standard
Republican voters
again that's the thing I'm not a trump
fan I want to make that clear not a
trump supporter and any shape or form
he's a champion
enthusiasm you know I've got the poacher
above my bed but when people talk about
Trump particularly people on the left
and they're very critical of him and
this happens for brexit as well my
response is always the left created
Trump the left created brexit because
there was a there's a whole swathe of
people
in the United States in Britain that
have felt left behind with the electoral
system they feel that the elites don't
represent them they've never cared about
them you know they've seen the
industrialization they've seen their
jobs their societies be absolutely
gutted financially their hearts and
souls ripped out of them and the parties
like labor Or democrats who always
purported to support who always
purported to care about the working
classes effectively abandon them so when
this person came in
I've always say to them and again I'm on
the left may I reiterate that it's our
fault we didn't care about them so we
have helped to create this phenomenon
I mean yeah people can say that but I
mean like that's kind of like the that's
just like the the rhythm of politics
throughout all of humankind right like
arguably the left created Trump for sure
but the left that existed before Trump
that was created by conservatives for
sure
um right like the rapidly homophobic the
massive warmongering in the United
States
um the the super anti-lgbt Obsession the
like all of that stuff of course that
created this fervent left that was like
oh well I hate you guys like we need to
have gay marriage and you know you guys
are against abortion yeah so I mean like
yeah of course both sides are our
reactions to what the other side is
doing and that's not a new thing right
like Trump being created as some radical
left group of people in the United
States yeah I believe that of course but
like that radical left didn't come from
nowhere either that was created out of
radical conservatives for a long time
too that's just how that that's the
rhythm of politics right okay and if not
it's a rhythm of politics would you
agree that things have become more
heated now the things yeah so I guess my
question is to you is somebody who's
obviously very intelligent and
understands politics how do we take the
temperature down how do we get better
candidates for America because I think
we can both agree Bobby and Trump don't
represent the best of your country uh
well Biden Biden's my guy every guy
represents a lot of good Americans but
um obviously as a main fan I would say
that but I I would say that the the
number one issue that we have right now
is probably the internet uh it's given
us the ability to self-segregate in ways
that we never have before I can hyper
fixate and find any piece of information
that I want to support any story that I
want and then I can join another group
of people and we can all share it
amongst ourselves and they're a huge
financial incentives for honing in on
the pieces of information that people
want and serving it to them and I think
all of these things kind of like play
really toxically on on human psychology
and combined with capitalism
um basically make this huge pot of gold
waiting for anybody that can figure out
how to serve you the most content that
you want that agrees with what you
already agree with over and over and
over and over and over again and I yeah
I think the internet is like uniquely
accelerated that problem yeah I couldn't
agree with you more man and we we do our
best to to stay away from that when we
can and of course it's very easy to look
around and go oh there's somebody else
who just wants to feed their Their
audience red meat all day long
um so you you answered very well for
answers questions about where it's
coming from but you didn't answer how do
we address it what do you think
um
uh this is where I give you the answer
that I showed at you for giving me about
the family stuff I don't it's a big
problem
so this is the number one issue and the
so if you've ever I agree I agree it's
the number one issue by the way well no
why so here's a problem okay in order to
fix anything first you have to recognize
what the problem is but most people
won't actually recognize the problem
um I'm 33 when I was a kid uh there was
this idea that the internet was going to
be this amazing thing because now you
can look up whatever piece of
information you want you've got so much
at your fingertips a lot of the internet
and the information age rests on this
absolutely faulty idea that humans are
intrinsically truth-seeking machines and
that is absolutely not true we do not
gravitate towards things that are true
we gravitate towards things that make us
feel good and as the internet gets
larger and larger and more information
is put out there you know people keep
saying well the studies are available
there's Wikipedia there's fact Checkers
there's news sites there's YouTube
there's all the stuff you should know
what's true and what's not true it
doesn't make any the reason why that
doesn't work is because people aren't
seeking out what's true they're seeking
out what's entertaining or what makes
them feel good about themselves well
you're not generalizing because
I am not perfect I am not perfect and I
definitely like to have my opinions
confirmed but one of the things we've
really tried very carefully to do on the
show is to genuinely seek truth and to
change our mind when we're confronted
with facts and to discuss things with
people who have different opinions and
our audience some of them like it some
of they don't but generally speaking we
don't give a [ __ ] because we believe
that's the mission of trigonometry and
the people who want that will come and
we see we just interviewed a guy called
called Isaac Saul who's created a
website which is like a media website
that both conservatives and liberals
rate very highly on trust because it
covers things objectively and and so do
you not think like you were talking
about politics where you get Action
Reaction there will also be a reaction
against this Echo chamberness that we
are seeing now and I think quite a lot
of people I mean you yourself aren't you
an example of this you were somebody who
was feeding red meat or blue meat or
whatever to your audience and then you
decided you didn't want to do that
anymore
um I try not to but the difference is
that like I go out of my way to have
like there are different things that I
do to make sure that I'm not just doing
the echo chamber thing
um so uh for instance for any topic that
I debate I can always convincingly
debate the other side there's not a
single issue that I argue on where I
can't give the other side's argument
better than anybody really that would
debate on it because I've heard all of
the best Arguments for it so there's a
lot of clips of me like arguing uh like
this is why the Holocaust didn't happen
or this is why black people deserve
whatever blah blah and it's just me
providing the other side and like this
is what they would say sounds like great
content yeah people will clip and go oh
my God but I'm just saying that like so
that's one thing I'll do right I'll make
sure that like okay yeah you know
whatever whatever I'm arguing I can
always argue the other side I'm not just
giving my points that's one thing a
second thing I'll do is um any time I
hold a position on anything I'll always
ask myself the question what would it
take to change my mind on a particular
issue and if I don't have an answer for
that if there's nothing that would
change my mind then I know that I'm
getting lost down some type of like Echo
chamber
um there's a bunch of other smaller
things but like those are two big things
that I'll try to keep in mind when it
comes to like forming and solidifying my
political opinions and arguing with
other people but I find that a lot of
people don't do any of these things
there's a lot of people I ask like okay
well how strongly do you believe in this
thing what is the strength of your
conviction I'm like oh I would say it's
like a nine out of ten I'm like wow um
like how much research do you do and
it's like well I listened to a Joe Rogan
podcast on it okay what would it take to
change your mind it's like I don't know
if you could change photos you have a 9
out of 10 conviction on something you
heard one time in a podcast on a podcast
and nothing can change your mind over it
um I think that's the majority of people
you're making good points but that isn't
what I was saying what I was saying is
if you're seeking the truth and we are
seeking the truth as best we can we're
not perfect none of us none of the three
of us are of course but if we're doing
that why why don't you think that other
people also want that
um I just don't think there's much of a
reward for it it's pretty rare like I
built a brand off of that kind of stuff
but I've also paid like a really heavy
price for it too now I'm lucky that I'm
big enough online that I can afford to
pay some prices but
um there's a lot of money in there's a
concept called audience capture where
you begin to deliver a certain type of
content your audience likes it and then
you keep feeding them what they want and
that's like where most of the money
online is to be made you know people
will constantly say this thing media
media is a reflection of what the people
want but all the people do is complain
about the media however
um people will complain I don't like the
media they're too sensationalist they're
too radicalized they're too horrible but
then you look at the media they consume
they're not watching like NPR or PBS or
like these boring dry documentaries
they're watching people screaming at
each other about how like we need to go
and kill all of these people and we need
to throw these people in jail when it's
like bro you're consuming exactly the
type of media that is being served to
you like of course again again not I
know I keep positioning myself as This
brilliant counter example but I've
stopped watching lots of people who went
down the path that you talk about I'm
not going to name names but there are
lots of people who started out for
example uh being like hey I'm a liberal
I'm just asking questions about you know
and and before you know it they are like
this massive conservative I'm like well
that's not interesting to me right and
well that's awesome if you do that
that's awesome but like I'm pretty sure
Tim Poole is like one of the most
popular like what like second or third
most popular media podcast
that guy's Off the Wall a lot you know
like yeah I well I've been on his show
and I I challenge them he immediately
unfollowed me on Twitter afterwards
but that's not my point my point is if
there are people like you and if there
are people like us isn't isn't that
actually reason for optimism and if if
there if we are doing that they've got
to be other people there who are not
content creators who are also interested
in that process of de-radicalization if
you want to call it that oh sure I think
it's possible yeah
um I I think there is cause to be
optimistic for it I think something
that's happened over the years is people
that are correct are still assume that
they don't have to dress their message
up at all because they're factually
correct and what's happened is is over
the over the years over a decade
um basically people that are I would say
are incorrect have spent so much time
dressing their message up to make it
exciting entertaining easily palatable
and they've done a really good job of
growing audiences while people who are I
would say more factually correct are
just lazy and boring and they don't do
much to make their their message more
um yeah digestible to people so I think
audience
well not or even myself like because I
would say by myself for a long time like
oh yeah there's no point in arguing this
like people just want Sensational
content blah blah blah but I think if
you if you put a lot of effort into
making like good content around stuff
that isn't like super politically
radical I think you can get viewers
doing it that's that's my current
political projects what I'm trying to do
but that's what we're saying yeah yeah
yeah
and and I think it's important as well
it's to give have faith in your in in a
not in the audience and have faith in
your fellow human beings because it's
very easy you know and look I do it as
well when you see these you know so and
so destroyed so and so whatever it may
be they get huge views you think oh this
person or all these people love this and
he goes just because something is
popular actually doesn't mean that
people enjoy
doesn't mean that they find it rewarding
you know if you look at the mainstream
media one of the biggest interviews in
the history of the internet in UK media
was when Channel 4 interviewed Jordan
Peterson
and it was kind of a gotcha style
interview and that and it could and that
produced the saying so what you're
saying is right because she kept trying
to misrepresent and it got huge views
but it really destroyed Channel 4's
reputation I mean there are a lot of
people and anecdotally and people that I
talked to who saw that as a time when
the mainstream media lost their way not
just channel 4. so I think it's
important to have faith in people and
realize that a lot of people want to be
treated like adults as well
um yeah I mean I would hope so yeah I
mean that's the direction that I'm
pushing my political content so
hopefully yeah yeah and you said you
paid
for for your
for using and your opinions what do you
mean by that Destiny what is the heavy
price
um well I mean I didn't tell the line on
the writtenhouse thing I felt pretty
strongly about that and I it cost me a
partnership on Twitch
um I get into fights with a lot of what
I would consider very radical trans
people and that I think arguably cost me
my account on Twitch
um so yeah I mean depending on who I'm
finding with at any point in time uh
depending on how principled I want to be
in my positions it can get me into a lot
of trouble but and what was your your
beef with the transition I'm curious
um I don't believe that trans women and
CIS women should be competing together
in the same athletic events I don't
think that there's a good argument for
that you lost your Twitch account for
that
um I don't I don't know I can't I can't
honestly tell you all I know is that my
account got banned the next day for it
said hateful speech but they don't tell
you exactly what it was so but I don't
use like I don't use transphobic slurs
like I'm very pro-trans I don't use any
like slurs or anything like that so I'm
not I'm not I don't really know what my
account got banned for I just what does
it mean that you're very pro-trans
um I think that trans people are real I
think that they're entitled to
um some type of medical treatment
um
I I probably would support minors
seeking medical treatment depending on
the roadblocks that are there or the
path to getting medical treatment there
just depends on the particular issue
okay so so you would see uh miners what
are we talking about with with minus
Destiny at what age would you say
somebody should be allowed to seek uh
medical treatment
um all of it's going to come down to
what the I guess what clinically becomes
like the most effective line of
treatment but essentially if somebody
knows I think that if by like 1314 when
you especially when you start going
through puberty you're going to know if
you're trans or not you're going to
definitely feel event now some people
might think they're trans but they're
not but if they are trans they'll know
it then um so we need to figure out
better forms of therapy or counseling to
where we can weed out the people that
probably aren't trans and are having
other problems in their life versus the
ones that definitely are trans so that
hopefully you can avoid them going
through like I guess like the
catastrophic male puberty for trans
women is the thing that [ __ ] them up a
lot right well would you agree that's
actually I think a quite a healthy way
to a large extent of looking at it which
is we need to make sure that the people
who are getting the physical and
hormonal transition really are the ones
that are like definitely definitely
trans because
we've seen in this country I don't know
if you're familiar with the Tavistock
Clinic uh and all the associated things
that have been going on in this country
but we've seen thousands of people now
suing because they were encouraged to
transition when perhaps it wasn't the
right decision for them uh would you
agree that we probably went too far in
that direction at some point
um it's possible that the thing is it's
hard to say like are we going too far
I'm sure that you could find examples of
going too far and so there's thousands
of examples this is what I'm saying
thousands of detransitioners thousands
of people suing sure I understand what
you're saying but you the UK has a
population like 70 million people so
when you say thousands of examples I
don't know if that means much right
um so I I agree that we can probably
find lots of examples of people going
too far but you would have to agree that
there's probably lots of examples of not
going far enough like I'm pretty sure in
the United Kingdom the wait time for
hormone therapy or related stuff even if
you have gone through the whole process
you're fully approved it's like two to
four years which is horrible right if we
if we if we do this is what happens when
you have socialized Healthcare you
you're gonna wait for an ambulance for
about 40 hours in this country well
thankfully in the United States you
don't have to wait you just died because
you can't afford the treatment so I mean
they're both bad options
um yeah well I mean you guys spend way
less on your health care than we do and
you we seem to have comparable outcomes
so I mean uh we do you know that the
National Health Service is like the the
fourth biggest employer in the world I
think in this country so we spend quite
a lot on Healthcare let's not open that
yeah we still spend probably in the
United States but like four times more
U.S spending on like if I were to check
like the United States more money than
anyone else in the world on Healthcare
it's insane well of course you're the
richest country in the world but look
um let's come back to the trans issue
because this is kind of important yes I
am sure that there are some trans people
for whom uh who ended up having to wait
too long for hormones I think that's a
lot less bad than people no offense I'm
going to put it quite bluntly chopping
the dick off when they didn't mean to
um yeah but like the problem is like the
the less bad thing like it feels like
any so let's see a child's chopping the
dick off seems like quite a big problem
to me yeah but also somebody killing
themselves because they're not allowed
to get treatment because conservatives
don't believe trans people are real
that's also really hold on hold on first
of all I'm not a conservative secondly I
didn't say you were but I'm saying
that's the other end of the article are
you arguing with me not with
conservatives right so let's have the
debate between me and you not okay well
but I'm not in favor of children
chopping their dicks off if they're not
actually trans so I don't know who
you're arguing with for that point right
no no you said that you you I actually
agreed with you I said I think you're
right to say that that people need to be
weeded out I think it was the term you
used yeah to to make sure that people
who are going through transition are
definitely definitely definitely the
people who need it right and what I'm
saying to you from my perspective we
have thousands of people who did do that
who were not actually trans and who
needed help for autism or who needed
help for some other kind of thing that
they were dealing with right and isn't
that a problem that shows that we went
way too far in that direction causing
thousands of young children to be
injured and maimed for life okay are you
saying that in the United Kingdom there
were thousands of children given sex
reassignment surgery like there were
thousand so if you and we have thousands
of people suing the Tavistock Clinic
there's probably more than that hold on
hold on I'm asking very specifically
because you're saying that there were
thousands of children in the UK that
would be tremendous if that was the case
um you're saying there are thousands of
children minors
um under in the UK is a 16 under 18 or
18 where had sex reassignment surgery
that means no no they had some form of
medical treatment in that area so either
hormones oh or what do you mean oh
hormones change your biology just just
the same well
there's a huge difference between a 15
year old one on puberty blockers for a
year versus a 15 year old had their
penis chopped off those are not to say
that either is okay but like the puberty
that's my point neither is okay but
their worlds apart in terms of like harm
they're not Worlds Apart if you take
puberty blockers that has a huge impact
on fertility on your life on your voice
on your physical appearance we see
people who who are basically young women
with beards now you think that's not a
big transition for someone to go through
I didn't say it wasn't a big transition
so that's all I'm saying no no no hold
on you said that it's not Worlds Apart
I'm telling you that it is world I
didn't say it's not Worlds Apart
yeah okay I'm saying that it is Worlds
Apart the difference between being on
puberty block is for a year versus
having your genitals changed
is huge right
of course can be bad okay okay the
difference between being punched in the
face and beaten endlessly in the face is
quite big I think that a young child
being punched in the face is bad sure
okay yeah I agree with that okay if it
is the case that there are people that
are um inappropriately issued or
prescribed medications or whatever as
minors
um that sucks what we have to figure out
is like what is the cost benefit right
like let's say for instance it's the
case that 10 children per year are
prescribed something that they didn't
need and 10 000 children per year are
prescribed something they did need
that'd probably be an acceptable
trade-off but if it's like a hundred
thousand children a year given something
they don't need and a thousand children
a year give me something they do need
that would be a totally unacceptable
trade-off right so this is what I'm
saying we have thousands of people suing
one Clinic one clinic in this country
and this problem is even worse in the
United States statistically speaking we
have thousands of people it is thousands
of people is it doing one yes yes I
don't think it is well this is why you
and I might agree because you have you
have paid medicine there's the financial
incentive to encourage this as well but
just stick with this point with me right
Okay thousands of children over a
thousand people suing the Tavistock
Clinic because they believe they were
giving the wrong treatment in relation
to transition and it's my view that the
reason that that happened is that there
was ideological capture you talk about
audience capture there was ideological
capture in these left-wing institutions
as we talked about before that encourage
this process and ended up taking it way
way way past the line that you and I
both agree
is the right line which is let's make
sure these people are definitely trans
before we start cutting things off them
yeah I mean I I yeah I'm not sure where
the disagreement is like if there are
medical practitioners I'm asking you do
you think we went too far given that
those were the results
holistically no for this one Clinic yeah
possibly it sounds like it you're saying
that they're going to be in the process
of suing them I don't know what that
case is going to look like until it
starts to play on the courts but it
could be the case if this Clinic went
too far yeah
okay if a thousand women sued me uh on
allegations of sexual harassment would
you conclude that I was a stand-up guy
no right that's kind of what I'm getting
at no no no no do you see the difference
though if you would ask me do you think
that the Tavis stock Clinic went too far
I would say yeah of course it sounds
like it for sure it does but you're not
asking me you're asking me if the whole
of trans stuff in the world has gone too
far and then you're sending me one court
case
um that is that hasn't even started yet
where families might sue the um have a
stock I mean I personally know like 10
people uh that I've spoken to who are
detransitioners who what encourage down
this path in your country not ours uh
that that are public about it now
imagine how much it takes to go public
after you've gone through that I imagine
there's quite a lot of people in America
who've gone through the same process who
are not happy about it yeah but there's
probably a lot of other people on the
other side too who are trans and could
never get medical treatment or was never
taken seriously or had horrible problems
their whole lives and nobody saw them
either right
I mean I don't agree with that but let's
let's
hold on how can you not agree with that
you don't think
you're suggesting that in the current
climate there are people who are being
denied the transition yeah if you live
in like Louisiana or Indiana or
Mississippi or if you're one of these
states or whatever you don't think some
of these people could be born to
families that don't believe in trans
people or in communities that don't
think that trans people are real that
don't want to come out or don't even
know about the idea of it yeah of course
and go to another state
that no no in the United States we don't
have buses like you guys do okay we have
school buses
hold on get on a plane come on can you
just rent a flat in London and go work
no of course these things are expensive
right
um well I just want to be clear you
can't afford a 300 fly if you're gonna
get hundreds of thousands of pounds or
dollars of surgery
for it's not just about getting the
surgery you're jumping ahead to the most
radical thing a lot of trans people that
are fully transitioned don't even get
sex reassignment surgery that's like the
most extreme thing but no I don't think
the average teenager in the United
States who's 14 15 16 years old can
afford a 300 plane ticket I don't think
so I don't even know if you're allowed
to fly as a minor without an adult a
company you're not allowed to fly but
you're allowed to choke your dick off
that seems quite extreme you're I think
okay I like
I'm acknowledging I I'll make the
acknowledgment that like there are there
are clinics and there are people that
have suffered ideological capture and
have gone too far with some of the trans
stuff I agree with that in terms of
diagnosing people but to say that like
it's never happened on the other end I
don't think that that's an honest
that's not I'm just saying it's never
happened I'm just saying I think we went
too far towards one side rather than the
other and I will grant you 50 years ago
yeah I don't think trans people had a
great life I I think we can all agree on
that okay
yeah okay okay good we'll leave that
there because I think we've both said
basically what we both mean right okay
so just stay with the Trans issue but uh
a different part of it what do you think
about with gender ID uh Destiny somebody
identifying as a woman and then having
access to women's spaces do you think
that that is do you agree with that or
do you disagree with that uh I don't I
don't agree with the self ID position at
all no
okay interesting why
uh it just doesn't it's a totally
incoherent position
um if we believe that gender is real
which I think we used to um if trans
people believe that gender are you real
which a lot of them do but some of the
more extreme ones don't um then that has
to be reducible to some real facet of
your brain and it can't just be that you
are what you say you are that doesn't
make any sense there has to be an
underlying fact of the matter you can't
just identify something and be something
so yeah I don't I don't think that you
can just identify as whatever and then
get access to whatever there has to be
some process to verify or validate
whatever it is you're identifying as
okay and do you think for instance uh
trans women should have access to
women's spaces
um if they're you know if they've if
they've gone part of the way there etc
etc etc
um it depends on what they present as I
mean like if they if they present as a
woman and they look like a woman and for
all intents and purpose it seems like
then yeah they probably should yeah
okay and what about when it comes to
things like women's refuges women's
prisons it's well there are vulnerable
women do you think that it should be a
space for biological women only
um almost certainly not but those get
more complicated
why are you so much certainly not
uh because I because nobody agrees with
that position that's insane
there were people who who certainly
agree with that position that's only
because they haven't thought about it
much like
no no I would disagree with that yeah
I'm curious do either of you have
daughters
oh no no okay if you had a do you know
who Buck Angel is yes you've had them on
the show would you want your daughter
sharing a jail cell or a shower or a
bathroom with Buck Angel because that's
a silence okay so what's a biological
female so when people say like only
biological condition but like I don't
know what people mean by that that
sounds insane to me I think that there
are people that have transitioned far
enough where it's obvious they should be
housed differently now if you're like a
huge Burly guy and you've got a huge
beard and huge muscles and you're like
well I'm a woman and I identify then no
[ __ ] you either go somewhere else or
figure something else about it but for
people that are like clearly passing
right like I don't think I would want to
be in in some space with my son if we go
to like a sauna or some [ __ ] I don't
know people do that and all of a sudden
somebody steps in and they've got these
huge knockers these massive you know 34
double triple d's and I'm like whoa what
are you doing in here that's a little
bit strange like oh well I'm a
biological male even though I've got
like bread I'm fully passing and fully
but like that's just weird to me I think
it's going to depend a lot on if the
person is passing or not that makes
sense yeah I find I agree with you so uh
and let's go to another issue that I
think you and I probably will agree on
hopefully which is the war in Ukraine
because I find that absolutely
mind-boggling how both a section of the
left and right have come up with all
sorts of crazy conspiracy [ __ ] about
that that they indulge in
um simply because they want to oppose
the current thing what have you made of
all of that
um I I said for a while in the United
States probably around the world there's
kind of this big like populist Rift and
I think that populists in general feel a
certain way about things and there's a
lot of populists on the left and right
and so they all kind of like come
together on how they view a lot of
Ukrainian stuff
um so like a populist might tend to be
like isolationist or might tend to be
like not involved in foreign affairs so
they'll see us sending any money to a
country as like evil or horrible and
everybody's got problems with their
countries in the west so they'll say
like well Russia is better or the West
is corrupt and blah blah blah um or
they'll say things like I don't trust
Western media but then they'll start
giving you news from Russia Today like I
don't know it's all just I think like my
opinion populism is like a brain rap but
yeah I think it all comes that's that's
what I find very audit people when
people rightly say they don't trust the
Western mainstream media I think they're
right not to I think the way the Western
mainstream yeah but if you say that you
don't trust Western media then you sign
me Russia Today all you've told me is it
you've got like 65 IQ or you're in the
middle of a stroke like there's just no
you said it better than I ever could or
would uh well said well guys send in
your questions for us and this Destiny
we've had a robust debate about all
sorts of things or maybe uh talk about a
couple of questions that we had on
locals ask our last question anything
else you want to bring up as I've sort
of talked over no no no it's it's fine
so you're a big fan of Biden then
Destiny yeah I am yeah okay and look
there's I know a lot of people on on the
left on the Democratic left who really
dislike Biden he means his girlfriend
there's people you know on the right who
obviously dislike Biden there's people
who say you know that that he's this is
a man who is very elderly he's in
cognitive decline that he shouldn't be
in charge of the most powerful nation in
the world so explain to us why is it
that you lot are abide and supporter
um I think Biden has done a really good
job at quelling the radical aspects of
the left in the party he was really big
on condemning the violence during the
BLM riots which I thought was really
good he has an acquiesced um or given in
to any of the weird socialist Kami [ __ ]
on the left which I think is really good
um he's done a fairly admirable job or
actually more than average over working
with Republican lawmakers to pass like
major legislation which I think is
really good he's repeatedly said that
he's trying to be the president of both
the left and the right when he's calling
out people on the right he's trying to
specify that it's like just the like
these Mega people
um and not necessarily all Republicans
um yeah I just think he's made I think
he's been like legislatively effective I
think his foreign policy has been pretty
good um I think he's just done all
around like way better than I expected
him to and I hope he continues to do
decently yeah right but don't you think
that's very antagonistic about the Maga
like surely if you want somebody to
change their mind if you want people to
come over to your side to your way of
thinking or not even that or adopt a
more mainstream position but
antagonizing those people is that really
the right Thomas
um I mean any leader has to be able to
call out like problematic aspects of his
team I mean there is a huge issue with
people in the United States that still
deny the results of the last election so
I mean you have to be I think France's
point is is attacking them going to
convince them otherwise
um
I I mean I don't know if it's going to
convince him otherwise but he has to say
something about it it can't just remain
silent on the issue where you've got
this growing wing in your country that
is
denying the results of the election
but wouldn't a more conciliatory time
wouldn't a tone that actually tries to
get through to someone
and be like I said more conciliatory
there's nothing to be conciliatory about
though these people are saying that the
election was stolen they're Biden is a
false president that Biden is being
controlled and he's senile that the all
the vaccine stuff is rigged and untrue
like there's nothing to concede to these
people I don't think you can concede
anything
um they're insane the the mega aspect of
the Republican party is actually [ __ ]
crazy and the Republicans are starting
to realize it now as they're starting to
all break down against each other
okay uh I'm curious about the senile
point because I I've not followed Joe
Biden's presidency that closely I I
actually agree with you on on aspects of
his foreign policy and I think you're
right that uh I mean he didn't go as far
to the extreme left as and someone else
might have done because I think he's a
sort of center-left uh guy but do you
not cringe when you see a clip of him
struggling to get a sentence out
um it's a little bit cringy nowhere near
as cringy as Trump's daily petulant
child tweets were though but I mean
those are pretty [ __ ] cringe I agree
also sometimes entertaining but but
again you've gone to like what about I
think our point oh yeah I mean like
Biden definitely is slowing down in his
older years yeah of course for sure he
is okay yeah okay but I mean like I only
get to vote on two people in my federal
election I agree I agree I think Francis
earlier question was much more apt which
is like are these two people the best
representatives of America uh I hope I
really hope not is I guess uh how I feel
about it and when well and what about
the withdrawal from Afghanistan do you
know what I think that was Major that
was uh that majorly tarnished his
reputation the fact it was so badly
handled
um I all I all I'll say is I'll give
them credit for actually pulling out I
mean Trump had drawn our troops down to
like I think four digit levels there
um I mean it sucked that
um
I mean obviously the images of like
people being airlifted off of embassies
after about so that wouldn't happen was
pretty shitty but we got out as well as
we could have
um I mean yeah what are you gonna do
all right now let's do some super chats
if you're up for it and we'll do some
more questions in a second Anton can we
uh pull up the the Super Chat we've had
a bunch send more in uh whether you
agree with Destiny or with us or with us
both or disagree with all of us let's
have some good uh questions and talk
about it uh and we'll get a couple of
the locals questions first uh so Wuhan
wetmarket says as a joke that will make
him laugh very hard you should ask him
what an nft is I don't know what that's
about
um a damn interview I did a long time
ago with a guy who didn't know what nfts
were okay I still don't really
particularly know but he actually nobody
does so you're good good uh he he uh he
mentions also that you came under Fire
for being a is this true being an
acquaintance of Nick Fuentes
um I did a lot of debates with um
Fuentes a lot of people don't like it
when I um a lot of people don't like it
when I talk to like anybody that's like
radical on one side or the other
especially on the right thing and I had
Fuentes was like over my house and we
did conversations we went out to eat and
did conversations and [ __ ] A lot of
people got really triggered about that
so but yeah it doesn't surprise me I
mean he does strike me I mean all your
criticisms of the Republican right I
think multiply them about by a thousand
add genuine racism anti-Semitism white
supremacy to that and that's what you
get with Nick Francis isn't it yeah yeah
okay yeah
look but that clearly I mean you clearly
believe that free speech is important so
you're one of those people that does
yeah for sure I mean I would hope that
like through enough conversations that
you can show that like these ideas are
not good or wrong or like I think it's a
more effective way of combating things
than just like screaming people down or
saying that we can't talk to these
people or whatever I don't I don't
believe in that approach and how did you
debate with him go
um I thought all of them went really
well
um we had a huge thing on 911 that I
thought was like pretty funny
um and then we had a couple
conversations that I thought went pretty
well for me but yeah
and uh John Bryce says do you believe
awoke ideology is the way of the future
for the west or is it a passing fad
um it's probably some kind of fad
everything seems to be a fad these days
we'll see where we end up in a few years
yeah
uh let's uh are you able to pull super
chats up well let's go let's get one up
yeah there we go so this is from Brendan
O'Leary and he says uh capitalism is
evolution socialism is creationism and
communism is its intelligent design
Theory discuss
intelligence so we're back at University
here yeah wait can you repeat that again
it's it's on the screen you should be
able to see it well I think what Brendan
is basically saying is uh socialism and
communism are as dumb as as denying
Evolution uh but I get the sense that
you're not particularly in favor of
those things anyway right so uh yeah no
I'm a huge anti socialism communism is
super stupid yeah okay cool next
okay and this is comp from calm on the
ground uh do do you think Destiny
there's a problem with the voting system
and if there is who do you blame for
that
uh I think the voting system works
really well I think the issue that we
have in the United States is that um
people uh the issue is that the voting
system right now is expressing the will
of the people really well which is that
we are historically [ __ ] divided and
we all hate each other
um so I mean like yeah I think the
voting system works fine people are just
mad because nothing's happening but
nothing's happening because I think
we're super divided that's well what
about how long it takes to get the
results I mean there are like third
world countries that can get the results
on the day and you guys have to wait for
weeks often
um I mean it depends on how we do the
types of votes but if you don't like it
I guess change the way the votes are
counted but I mean there are also
probably third world countries that rig
their voting system and there are I
don't know how many people are voting in
different types of countries but yeah
well like Brazil got the results on the
night
good for Brazil yeah
okay so you're not bothered by that no
worse uh cool thank you next Anton let's
go uh Richard the horse says how much do
you think your views are purely based on
fact versus your interpretation of fact
based on your values or view of human
nature
um I mean I'm gonna give you the answer
that every single person will give you
and I'm going to say I hope all of my
views are based on fact
um or I mean I guess your interpretation
of facts is how a person views facts but
um
yeah
okay okay
uh next please Anton
uh we're actually Destiny we didn't ask
you the question we always ask at the
end uh which is what do you think is the
one thing that we're not talking about
as a society that we really should be
um I feel like getting people to come
together and have conversations is
really important even if people still
disagree I think it keeps both sides
rooted a little bit more firmly in
reality when they're talking to each
other when they stop talking to each
other both sides run off into extremely
crazy territory
okay next ready Anton okay uh so uh JS
Powell asks what are your views on Net
Zero
um 82nd Net Zero missions yeah yeah I
think that's an awesome thing to do I
don't know if it's gonna happen in like
five to ten years or or 2050 or whatever
people are pointing towards
um I mean that that should definitely be
like the direction that we're aimed in
but we have to balance out our desire
for net zero emissions with uh whatever
realistic energy policies we can have to
make sure people aren't like dying in
the streets of like coldness and [ __ ]
right
um it's that's gonna be like um I think
Net Zero is as much an economic question
as it is uh you know like a social
policy or whatever yeah well it's kind
of not how it's being pursued certainly
not in this country at the moment where
in Winter thousands of pensioners died
because they can't afford to hit the
house because we've jacked up the price
of energy via various stupid energy
related policies but it sounds like
you're not in favor of that so you're
not in favor of pensioners freezing good
stuff all right thanks on the types of
it no I'm just kind of here but
folk said uh he says I've always uh
investigation is it of course was
excellent so kudos for that service so
tell us a little bit of what that was
about Destiny
um basically just a person that I had
huge disagreements with that was telling
a lot of lies about me the internet and
I did a huge investigation of this
person to prove that they were indeed
the liar go figure
okay perfect thanks box head appreciate
the Fiverr next what else we got into
one more
chaotic neutral with the five it says
how much do you think you affected snico
feels like he became a bit less unhinged
after talking to you
um hopefully a bit but I mean obviously
now he's in like way more radical
circles so I don't know how much effect
at all I have on him at this point
okay
all right man is there anything else you
didn't say or want to add before we wrap
up
um no I think that's it cool where can
people find you online
at youtube.com Destiny or instagram.com
Destiny Destiny thanks for joining us
and thank you guys for watching and
listening we'll be back uh tomorrow with
our usual raw shows and of course on
Sunday with another brilliant episode
like this one this week's episode is
with Ariel pink who I imagine Destiny
probably wouldn't like very much because
he attended a peaceful protest on
January 6th he didn't go to the violent
Rally or anything like that uh got
himself canceled anyway so we did a long
talk in which I challenge him just about
as much as I challenge Destiny including
about quite a lot of the conspiracy
theories that he has about lots of
things to do with politics so join us on
Sunday but of course we've got a full
program of raw shows for you this week
Thursday Friday and Saturday we'll see
you tomorrow and for those who like your
trigonometry on the go don't forget it's
always available as a podcast take care
and see you soon we'll see you on locals
guys bye are you tired of using bulky
old wallets giving you a bulge where you
don't want it to be my old wallet was
massive so it brought all the ladies to
the yard which was a huge distraction
and got in the way of my esteemed work
on trigonometry reg wallets have an
incredible solution for you this is mine
Sleek stylish and with an industrial
look to it can fit 12 cards with cash on
the back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
I've got one Francis has one even our
producer Anton has one but he's from
Liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about Ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life Ridge is so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because Ridge is such
great guys are going to give give you
three worldwide shipping and returns to
take advantage of this incredible offer
go to ridge.com forward slash trigger
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who cleanly executed for not
being real men which is correct well for
those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
bull deodorant crop reviver Turner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and we'll have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20. at manscape.com that's 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrade your life
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably run near like the
sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape uh not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one and only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys